une heure d'attenté en caisse dans cet
hypermarché lyonnais ce matin ça vous
rappelle quelque chose
il y a un nom avec la peur du
confinement les supermarchés étaient
pris d'assaut
des files d'attentes généré d'un côté
pour éviter les foules confinés à
l'intérieur et de l'autre provoquée par
un surnombre de clients qui anticipent
l'annoncent du confinement et sur les
parkings des coffres pleins à craquer on
avait fait plus de tout ce que
d'habitude j'en sais rien j'ai pris
n'importe quoi quel choix mais il ya
tellement de monk à manger pour combien
de temps ah là pour quinze jours trois
semaines des haricots verts du riz du
ton des choses simples a acquis début
mais emporté pour tenir le temps qu'il
faudra les français font des stocks
résultat les rayons se vident pâtes riz
papier toilette commence à manquer dans
le rayon les pattes se sont
littéralement volatilisé depuis une
semaine dans ce supermarché de nice les
spaghettis le riz la farine le lait les
conservent tous les aliments de première
nécessité disparaissent en quelques
minutes
autres produits de première nécessité
qui ont fait leur apparition il ya un an
les masques et le gel hydroalcoolique
eux aussi victimes de leur succès en a
vendu plus de 700 mhz à ce camp de jour
là déjà
donc c'est quand même assez
impressionnant une ruée en 48 heures
d'autres pharmacies sont elles déjà en
rupture de stock
après la ruée sur les masques va-t-on
vers une pénurie de gel hydroalcoolique
des officines ont été dévalisés depuis
quelques semaines les achats de gel
hydroalcoolique ont augmenté de 91 %
dans les grandes surfaces et à cause de
la pénurie
certains prix ont flambé il pleut sur le
fond peut croire disgrâce 990 mais sur
super chien à la fois d'être un message
que cela aux gens de partout les
personnes qui me les bombes et ils vont
brave augmenté de prix et de plus d'un
an les craintes de manque et les files
d'attentes aux supermarchés font partie
du quotidien des français
[Musique]